There are four quadrants
of your consciousness.
Upper left is what you know
and what people know about you.
Upper right is what you know
about yourself but nobody knows.
Lower left is what other people
know about you that you don't know.
And lower right is what you
don't know and what nobody knows.
Whims come from there,
impulses come from there,
and that's where art comes from.
When did you first start
taking pictures of people?
1976, I was finishing Boston Views,
the pictures people call topographic,
and I got tired of it,
and day by day,
just people started to creep in.
The minute you get
to a certain distance,
a certain closeness of the person,
then it's all about the person,
and the background becomes something
that has to be integrated
with the frame,
but it's not about
the overall view anymore.
Jan Groover said a good thing once.
When she went from painting
to photography, she said,
“It took me a while to figure it out
but in photography the problem
is making the grass
as interesting as the cow.”
The Brown Sisters is a series
of 41 photographs
of my wife Bebe
and her three sisters.
I've taken it every year
for 41 years.
I use the same camera every year,
8-by-10,
and they stand in the same order.
The only thing I really ever say is
“Get closer, please”
if the space between them is boring.
If they’re like here,
you have to stand further back,
and so their faces are smaller,
therefore less voluptuous
and less powerful physically.
So the closer they are together,
the more the physicality
of their faces and gestures,
the larger it is in the frame.
Okay, so it's going
to be half a second.
Okay, the cheek one again, please.
Now that I'm trying
to make digital work,
I started a series of two people
putting their faces close together,
touching, and letting
whatever feelings of discomfort
or comfort or amusement, fear, show.
Okay, close close.
I think it's letting me
be a little more intimate
and physical with people
than I've been able to be before.
How is the process different?
The process is just about my comfort,
that doesn't matter that much.
The more important thing
is how are the pictures different.
I want to get rid of the idea
that they have their private space.
They don't have any
in these pictures.
They're all in the same place,
like a subway.
They're all in a place
where they're forced
by the truc of the project
to do something unnatural
in order for something intense
to come out.
The slice of time that it takes
to take the picture is smaller,
so now it might be
a hundredth of a second
instead of an eighth of a second.
With an eighth of a second,
the person has to be aware of it
in a way that they
don't the other way.
I tend to like them to be aware of it
even with a digital camera anyway,
so I tend to do it the same way.
I want it to be longer lasting,
and have the meaning
be not about grabbing the moment
but about dancing with the moment,
collaborating with the moment.